HAVE A GREAT NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
STAY SAFE.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THAT EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
IF YOU ARE UNDER THE AGE OF A
HUNDRED YOU HAVE NEVER LIVED IN
A WORLD WHERE THAT
UNITED NATIONS WAS NOT THE MOST
POWERFUL COUNTRY ON EARTH.
FOR CENTURIES AMERICA’S
DOMINANCE HAS SHAPED THE GLOBE,
MANY OF OUR MOST BASIC
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE THINK OF
AMERICA, ABOUT DEMOCRACY,
CULTURE, ART AND THE VALUE OF
HUMAN LIFE ARE NOW MUCH OF THE
WORLD’S ASSUMPTIONS, AT LEAST,
OFFICIALLY.
THIS HAS BEEN AN AMERICAN
CENTURY BUT THERE IS NO MANDATE
THAT WE COULD LEAVE THE WORLD
FOREVER.
IN COUNTLESS WAYS THIS PANDEMIC
HAS SHOWED US THAT, IT HAS
REVEALED HOW TERRIFYINGLY TERRIF
VULNERABLE WE ARE.
WE KNOW LONGER MAKE MASKS HERE,
WE NEED SPECIFIC MEDICINES AND
WE KNOW LONGER NEED THOSE EITHER
EITHER.
CT SCANS IN AN ENDLESS LIST OF
OTHER CRITICAL DEVICES, NONE OF
THEM ARE MADE HERE ANYMORE.
JUST LIKE OUR PHONES AND OUR
ROUTERS AND OUR MACHINE TOOLS IN
OUR AIRPLANE PARTS.
CHINA MAKES AN AWFUL LOT OF WHAT
WE USE AND BY THE WAY, A LOT OF
WHAT OUR MILITARY USES.
CHINA HAS GROWN RICH FROM
SELLING ALL OF THIS TO US AND
THAT’S WHY WHEN WE NEED TO RAISE
MONEY IN A CRISIS, THIS CRISIS
FOR EXAMPLE, WE SELL OUR DEBT TO
CHINA.
IF AMERICA GOES BANKRUPT AFTER
ALL THIS, BANKRUPTCY AND THE WAY
THAT OUR LEADERS ARE RESPONDING
TO THE PANDEMIC THAT COULD
HAPPEN.
IT WILL LIKELY BE THE CHINESE
WHO BAIL US OUT, THEY ARE THE
ONLY ONES WHO CAN AFFORD IT.
ALL OF THIS IS REAL AND
HORRIFYING AND MOST OF US ARE
JUST WAKING UP TO IT NOW.
SO THE QUESTION IS, HOW DID IT
HAPPEN?
HOW DID THE WORLD’S RICHEST
DEMOCRACY BECOME DEPENDENT UPON
A HOSTILE FOREIGN DICTATORSHIP?
THERE ARE A LOT OF REASONS FOR
THAT.
OUR LEADERSHIP CLASS ALLOWED
THIS TO HAPPEN.
SOMETIMES THEY DID IT IN SECRET.
AND THEY GOT RICH FROM DOING IT.
LAST NIGHT WE TALKED TOLD YOU
ABOUT A CONSULTING FIRM CALLED
McKINSEY AND COMPANY.
McKINSEY IS THE RECRUITER OF
CHOICE FOR MANY GRADUATES.
PETE BUTTIGIEG DID OUT OF
HARVARD.
McKINSEY MAKES MONEY SELLING
ADVICE AND THAT ADVISE
SAUDI ARABIA’S CROWN PRINCE FOR
EXAMPLE HOW TO SILENCE ALL
DESCENT AND HIS KINGDOM.
IN THE 1980s, McKINSEY URGED
BANKS TO EXPAND SOMETHING CALLED
SECURITIZATION, THAT’S THE
PRACTICE OF SELLING BUNDLED
LOANS.
THAT PRACTICE LED DIRECTLY TO
THE 2008 FINANCIAL CRISIS.
McKENZIE PROMOTED A CONCEPT
CALLED OUTSOURCING.
U.S. COMPANIES THEY ARGUED COULD
INCREASE SHORT-TERM PROFITS BY
SENDING MANY OF THEIR JOBS
OVERSEAS.
KENZIE DEFENDED THIS PROCESS BY
PRODUCING IN-HOUSE RESEARCH
WHICH, IN THE END THEY THOUGHT
WOULD BE, IT DIDN’T HAPPEN.
AND EARLY ON, McKENZIE EVEN
OFFERED ITS SERVICES TO THE
COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA AT A
DISCOUNT.
THE MANAGING DIRECTOR SERVED AT
THE ADVISORY BOARD OF THE CHINA
DEVELOPING BANK WHICH IS THE
MAIN DRIVER BEHIND OF THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE AND BRUTAL KIND OF
COLONIALISM OF THE WORLD HAS
SEEN IN MORE THAN 100 YEARS.
SO CHINA ROSE AND AMERICA
DECLINED BUT McKENZIE STILL
FOUND WAYS TO MAKE MONEY HERE IN
THE U.S.
THE COMPANY ADVISED
PURDUE PHARMA ON HOW THEY COULD
"SUPERCHARGE SALES" OF THEIR
ADDICTIVE PAINKILLER OXYCONTIN.
McKENZIE URGED PURDUE TO USE
MAIL ORDERS TO BYPASS
PHARMACISTS THAT WERE TRYING TO
KEEP ADDICTS FROM GETTING
NARCOTICS.
McKENZIE ADVISED PURDUE ON HOW
TO "COUNTER THE EMOTIONAL
MESSAGES FROM OTHERS WITH
TEENAGERS WHO OVERDOSED ON
OPIOIDS.
CONSIDERING ALL THE INJURIES
THIS COUNTRY HAS SUSTAINED OVER
THE PAST 40 YEARS, THE LOSS OF
MANUFACTURING AND UNPRECEDENTED
DRUG ACADEMIC EPIDEMIC THAT HAS
CHANGED ART DEMOGRAPHICS,
LEADERS ALIGNING WITH FOREIGN
DICTATORSHIPS AND A FINANCIAL
ICE ECONOMY.
McKINSEY AND COMPANY IS
DIRECTLY IMPLICATED IN EVERY ONE
OF THESE DISASTERS.
THE TIES ARE ESPECIALLY